We have seen that we can If-Convert If-Then-Elses, A similar
technique would be very useful for a loop, but can
we [UNKNOWN] If-Convert a loop? Let's go back to our
loop that loads from some memory address, add something to
that, Stores that back in memory, adds 4 to the
pointer, to the beginning of the loop, unless the pointer
has reached some final value. Let's say that in this
processor, every operation takes two cycle to do. So we
will have a stall cycle here, because we need
to use R2 two cycles later, another stall cycle here
because the add needs to operate for one more cycle
before the store can see that value. There is no
stall cycle here because this add can actually proceed immediately,
it doesn't depend on the store, and then the branch
gets delayed by one more cycle because it's using the
result of the add. So we have three stall cycles
here, and again this is a process where every operation just
takes two cycles, we have already seen that we can schedule
this loop differently. So that we load and then we do
the add I and then we do the add, this way we
avoid this stall cycle here, however, after this add, the only
things that are left to do in this situation of the loop
are the store and the branch. We can not do the
branch before the store, so the store has to happen here, and
thus, we haven't eliminated this store cycle here. And
then the branch can check R1 for whether it reached
the final value here, because without a stall, because
R1 has been manipulated here and then we had to
change this store, if you remember, because the add
of a constant has moved here. So that it uses
a minus four offset to compensate for this, so we
manage to eliminate two of these stall cycles, but one
still remains, now it you look at this branch here,
If conversion would allow us to kind of do the
next iteration of the loop here. And then eliminate this
branch, because it would be predicated. And then we could maybe
find something here, that can go over here but the
problem is that. A loop is not really suitable for if-conversion,
because every time we have a new iteration we would
have to introduce a new predicate and then every new iteration
would introduce yet another predicate, and we simply cannot deal with
so many predicates and so many things that get done only
if the predicate is true. Pretty much if we are executing
a million iteration loop sometimes and sometimes only one ite,ration Then almost
a million iterations would have to be just predicated out which
would be very, very slow. So we want to do something about
loops that is like If conversion to allow us to kind
of find things in future iterations to move here, but without really
doing if conversion, So we cannot truly if convert but there is
something else we can do. And that something will be called loop unrolling.